it is your 10th anniversary here at cds
news and cbs mornings uh and we are
celebrating your impressive decade here
at the table with something that's
become a yearly tradition there's the
yellow dress yeah why did you wear
yellow on day one because yellow is my
favorite color yellow is my happy place
so believe it or not i spent a lot of
time trying to decide what to wear alex
cramer made the stress for me years and
years and years ago and i just yellow
just makes me happy
and i wanted to feel happy on that day i
was very nervous and it wasn't nervous
about oh god i don't know if i could do
it i was nervous because you just wanted
to do a good job right so we were all
feeling that everybody in this room was
there that day we were all feeling we
just wanted this program to work yeah
not coming any sense then yeah uh you
are a trusted authentic hard-working
journalist and you've had a lot of big
interviews over the years we're going to
look back at a few of them uh as well
some of the tougher stuff uh your
coverage from the border the u.s mexico
immigration crisis there uh presidential
interviews uh you got in a tunnel with
elon musk a big interview there uh
george floyd coverage that was sad
difficult stuff the me too movement
everyone remembers r kelly of course uh
jeff bezos uh you have an amazing
ability actually to talk to the most
famous and influential people on the
planet most powerful but at the same
time this is just the nature of our work
you often end up having to have
conversations with regular people on the
worst childhood lives and it's difficult
stuff and you put them at ease yes
welcome them into our living room and to
everyone else's and it's an amazing
skill well said tony so we're gonna look
back on all that plus the fun yeah uh
bruce springsteen you went to his farm
more overalls yes not yellow overall i
beg bruce springsteen for that interview
for five years to talk to him let's
watch the package and then we'll
reminisce a little bit on the back end
bright shiny faces
all in our places roll the tape miss
shantae
like that and come on cut move to
something else make it a little snappier
stop me before i start twerking stop me
i'll have a cheese i never asked you for
anything lenny are you going to wear
your sunglasses the whole time this is
early drew barrymore it's good to see
you and i wore yellow in your honor i
wore yellow in your honor you can't see
it right now
but i'm wearing spanx
[Music]
i love you love you too does my hat go
with my outfit you look lovely
exclusive
okay
put it out there
put it out man
did you say you're happier now than
you've ever been you got to work on it
every single day take a seat at the bar
why did they even call you the boss why
i don't even know it was all an accident
what do you mean
it was the ban started because i i paid
their paychecks and that's how it
started when you meet me you're kind of
this well you're you're i don't have
that
you're you you're the most i think i was
like what you get with me don't believe
me just watch well here we are in
campaign 2016. lots of people want your
job holy bee
you're getting go ahead i think
how fast is this we can get a hundred no
problem but we'll we'll take it easy for
you
we are loving our new home right here in
times square if i can make it here i can
make it anywhere
i love this hallie directed by halle
berry loves saying that
i love seeing that i saw words visionary
director a film by avery duvernay
how did you even think that was possible
or did you think that was possible no i
didn't dream of this yeah i didn't even
dream of it
i feel the need
[Music]
the best place to be for me is always
right yes indeed i still feel that the
best place to be at the table i really
do
i still after all this time still love
this job i just said to the driver
coming to jeff coming in this morning
that when you come on times square it's
lights camera action you look at the
billboards everybody's happy and smiling
i feel that way when i come into this
building i think it's an awesome awesome
job i think it's a lot of it's a
privilege but it's a great
responsibility and i don't take it
lightly i love being here with you guys
every morning i do you bring that energy
yeah i do you're one of the best in the
business i mean i don't know if i bring
the energy i just know i really like it
i just know i really really like it you
say the same thing every day when you
walk in the studio what do you say all
in our places
in the background
they go oh god she's here again
much appreciated and thank you for the
work oh thanks i'm thrilled thrilled
it's so funny because i looked at the
rundown when i came and i went
don't say nothing about my team see we
can surprise you a little bit i said
okay maybe we'll just say we'll pay a
tribute to the dress at the end and i
was fine with that so thank you
whoever did that tape thank you
i didn't know about this oh and gail you
love dessert oh yes i do
i do okay so we'll bring this closer
brian did you make that yourself
thank you
i'll let you dive into that while i'm
here
so pretty